the Google walkouts are shining a
spotlight on how the tech giant's treats
women thousands of employees left work
yesterday to protest revelations in the
New York Times that Google protected
three executives accused of sexual
misconduct and paid large reverences to
two of them one of those executives Andy
Rubin denied the claims made against him
he says this the New York Times story
contains numerous inaccuracies about my
employment at Google and wild
exaggerations about my compensation now
this is the latest protest in the year
of the me2 movement the nationwide
action also led to the creation of times
up an organization that insists on safe
fair and dignified work for women of all
kinds
Lisa borders is times up first president
and CEO her first day on the job was
yesterday she previously served as
president of the WNBA good morning to
you Lisa border good morning Gail great
be with you we're glad you're here so
take us through your day yesterday you
wake up and you see these headlines you
thinking I've work to do what were you
thinking my first thought was if there
were any question about the decision I
made to come two times up and begin this
work and join the folks who started this
in January of last year there was no
question that the universe affirmed it's
my decision it's unfortunate but I'm
here to do the work let's get started
what did you think about Google Google's
response and the fact that they're in
this conversation this way the first
thing I thought was it was stunning that
it was Google you think of them as a
tech giant you think of them as being
culturally relevant and resonant you
look at their doodles every morning and
you think they keep it real every day so
to see this walk out this global protest
against them was stunning it is not
surprising though when you think about
corporate America and how many
challenges we see in the boardroom and
the mail room with regard to women and
how we are treated not just in
corporations but in every sector in
every industry so your first day was
yesterday
what is the to-do list look like I mean
is it to fix and change things in the
boardrooms is it to help companies that
think gosh we even do we have just have
no idea where to begin or to there's a
whole huge legal side right so John we
cannot boil the ocean we're gonna work
in three sectors culture companies and
laws this
it's the Google situation Fitz frankly
in all three we are delighted that the
CEO spoke up yesterday mr. pitch I said
I agree with the workers I agree with
the women and the enlighten win who
walked out yesterday and said we have
some issues to address women and in
light men that is for sure all across
the globe so we applaud that that's
acknowledging the problem the question
now is how are you going to address the
problem when I thought about the Google
team if you will the Google family they
left notes on their desk as to where
they were going what they were doing why
they were protesting and they left five
issues on the table that they would like
to see address it was crisp it was
compelling it was clear the question now
is will the CEO and the board and the
Google team take them seriously and
respond not react respond and one of
those is pay transparency that we have
up on the screen right now you say that
is key for companies especially for
women to see what others are making to
have salaries be made known so they can
see whether or not they're underpaid
viana you're absolutely correct
transparency is key to opening up all of
this whether it's pay inequity or
opportunity inequity you shouldn't have
to know what's going on you should be
able to see it plainly the companies
have an opportunity here I think also an
obligation if you look at the data today
the diversity data that says when you
have people of different backgrounds
experiences skill sets and talents
working on any problem or any thing that
your company is working on the results
are better this is not Lisa's opinion if
you look at the price earnings ratios
and public companies the return on
investment
the data is clear these companies have a
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders I'm not gonna make the
moral argument may we start with the
economic argument you've also certainly
said that there's room for redemption I
think a lot of people may be surprised
to hear you say that what does that look
like
so anytime there's a crisis scale we
know that the formula is regret reform
and restitution once you have walked
through saying you're sorry once you and
you really mean it a sincere I'm sorry
then you talk about what you're going to
do to fix it and then how are you going
to take full accountability you need to
be brought
into the fold you can be the best ally
if you have done something wrong
and you are now walking in the light and
see a better way I'm going to perform a
better way and you are in fact redeemed
well we are walking into a heart out so
Lisa congratulations on a busy first
week we appreciate you being here thank
you so much great to be with you